cela nous permettra également de
répondre à cette question est sans merci
la parole et à monsieur alain suguenot
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre votre
secrétaire d'état en charge du budget
répondait hier à une de nos collègues
sur le prélèvement à la source de
l'impôt sur le revenu et je vous
interpeller sur l'opportunité d'une
telle réforme à cinq mois des élections
présidentielle et législatives
contrairement à ce que vous avez affirmé
cette réforme des pins site de modernité
et ne correspond pas à la révolution
fiscale que vous aviez pourtant promis
au début de cette mandature pire
l' usine à gaz que vous proposez va
induire une complexité nouvelle un
appauvrissement des contribuables qui
vont faire l'avancé l'état d'un apport
toujours aussi injuste une suspicion
vis-à-vis de l'employeur qui va prendre
la popularité de ce prélèvement est une
violation de la confidentialité liées au
secret fiscal
les autres pays qui mis en place un tel
prélèvement ne sont pas du tout dans la
situation avec elle se trouve la france
contrairement à ce que vous disiez et
cette option du prélèvement à la source
est aujourd'hui une antiquité 1920 en
allemagne 1941 aux pays bas nous sommes
sûrs plus loin de l'indignation de
l'impôt et n'avons même pas le bénéfice
de supprimer l'obligation de déclaration
le seul avantage est bien sûr pour
l'état qui va thésauriser pendant neuf
fois les crédits ou les réductions
d'impôts décourageant d'autant plus les
contribuables vertueux qui ont décidé
d'embaucher des emplois des disciples
ont entrepris des travaux d'économie
d'énergie
le remboursement n'intervient dans des
faits qu'en septembre de l'année
suivante ce qui va nuire très
sensiblement au pouvoir d'achat des
français qui n'ont pas besoin de cela
vous en conviendrez en ce moment
monsieur le premier ministre il n'y a
pas en france que des représentants de
la fonction publique il y aussi des
agriculteurs des entrepreneurs des
salariés des retraités qui se
souviendront longtemps hélas de ce
quinquennat et de la pression fiscale
sans précédent qu'ils ont eu à subir
monsieur le premier ministre ne croyez
vous pas que les français en ont assez
de ces réformes
très souvent inutiles et qui n'apporte
pas de réponses aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent quotidiennement la parle est
un monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget et des comptes
publics
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
ce n'est pas en dénonçant des
contrevérités que l'on fait une
politique la vérité elle est laquelle
monsieur le député vous parlez des
crédits et des réductions d'impôts
premièrement notez bien
que ce gouvernement propose dans ses
lois de finances de transformer la
réduction d'impôt qui n'était qu'une
réduction d'impôt sur les services à la
personne en un crédit d'impôt c'était ce
matin au salon des services à la
personne
ce matin même et j'ai pu mesurer
l'enthousiasmé du secteur devant cette
mesure alors les crédits d'impôts et des
réductions d'impôts monsieur le député
aujourd'hui avant le prélèvement la
sauce corps sont ils perçus par les
contribuables
exactement dans les délais que vous avez
indiquée aujourd'hui les crédits et les
réductions d'impôts sont perçues lors de
la liquidation de l'impôt c'est-à-dire
l'année suivant
qu'en sera-t-il avec le prélèvement à la
source si il n'y aura aucun changement
et si nous ne faisons pas rentrer dans
l'assiette de l'impôt
les revenus de 2007 nous matt de 2017
nous maintenant les crédits relais
réduction d'impôt en 2018 pour les
dépenses qui ont été faits notamment
pour les services à la personne en 2017
et monsieur le député si vous venez
demain ici dans cet hémicycle
vous constaterez qu avec les députés de
la majorité
nous introduirons une disposition
supplémentaires c'est à dire qu'à partir
de 2018 en février 2018
nous vous proposons qu'un l'anah compte
de crédits d'impôt de 30% des crédits
d'impôt de l'année précédente soit
versée dès le mois de février ce qui
sera un nouvel avantage supplémentaire
alors vous enragez monsieur le député tu
as eu la droite n'a jamais réussi à
mettre en place cette réforme
elle a annoncé l a dit qu'il suffirait
d'appuyer sur un bouton et bien c'est
cette majorité qui mettra en place cette
réforme